New York city mayor Eric Adams could be
in big trouble with crazy liberals in
his party after slamming woke Democrats
who he thinks are causing minority
voters to run away
there's a human of our Latino Community
our aapi communities that's leaving the
traditional democratic base is because
we've allowed the loudest and those who
consider themselves to be woke some of
us never went to sleep and we hear and
speak directly to people and I think the
party is now understanding that we have
to speak at those issues that are
important wait you mean Hispanics don't
like being called latinx Remember only
three percent of them actually use that
term
so uh do you guys need to hear from
mayor Adams more often
yeah I think that that's great but the
crazy liberals that he's talking about
didn't vote for Eric Adams he wasn't
their top choice for this he was seen as
the more conservative
um you know the former cop Etc so I'm
not sure how much it'll penetrate if you
have Alvin Bragg I don't know how far
you're going to get with it but I think
this kind of conversation is definitely
important and the most extreme example
or the one that I think should have kind
of sent shock waves throughout the
country was the recall in San Francisco
of Chessa Boudin was fueled by Asian
voters who were sick of racism were sick
of being beaten up having their stores
pillaged Etc and this is a typically
well obviously a left-leaning city but a
left-leaning voting Bloc and things like
that can happen in other liberals in
other liberal cities um so I I think
it's good that he calls it out he's in
the business of keeping people safe it's
like we said the other day Jazz white
Liberals are ruining this country
present company exclusive yes of course
no I include her
um the thing about latinx is that you've
got these people these walksters to they
try to Pro they try to impose their own
Concepts on the very people who don't
want those Concepts like the Latinos say
we've got Latinos to cover us we don't
need you to put this in promoter of
latinx and they come in and they they
impose all of these rules that I don't
know where they come up with them but
nobody's in support of them but because
they're the loudest group they get to
get all the attention and everybody gets
outraged over them and I think that the
the mayor coming out and talking about
this I give him credit I mean look I've
been very hard on the mayor I'm happy
when he talked about putting the
criminals who appear to have mental
health problems in a facility giving
cops the ability to do that now he's
talking about these walksters getting
you know real hard-working people to
move out of New York City and he's
starting to recognize what's important
and that is keeping people in New York
City who at least can give them a tax
base you know the walksters are like
they these progresses who even knows
where they're from or where they live
with the latinx thing Greg it's like if
we were in the minority and we were told
that we have to refer to ourselves as
Caucasians no I want to be white yeah
sorry latinx is a great website
yes mayor Adams is making a point that
has to be made that only basically he
can make and other is that most
minorities aren't into wokism you know
because they have bigger concerns right
they they don't pronouns and dead naming
that's not part of their lives and he
knows that he also knows that the woke
solve no real problems and the perfect
example is while children were
languishing during covid What were what
was the SF board doing school board
doing they were uh putting up you know
putting up decisions to change the name
of schools that helped no kid that
helped nobody so wokism ends up being a
luxury Bland a luxury brand for people
like Joy Reed right who is they can
espouse this harmful ideology that has
no detrimental effect at all on their
lives because they're removed from real
life so the woke you know they'll see 10
dollar eggs they'll see five dollar gas
they'll see Rising crime and say but
what about gender affirmation surgery
because they can afford the eggs they
don't drive right and they have private
security in their gated home so that it
really wokeism is really a luxury brand
it is and that's why white liberals rich
white liberals in Manhattan are the main
proponents of it
rui took Sarah who works now at the AEI
he was been a longtime Democrat and he's
been trying to get Democrats especially
in D.C to understand that they are
losing the working class and one of the
reasons is because of wokism and he
could he's basically talking himself
into circles but then maybe he's
breaking through because you've had some
people in pop culture who will do it
like Bill Maher once in a while but
what's interesting to me about mayor
Adams is where's the rest of the New
York delegation they don't do anything
but they're on Capitol Hill and they're
talking about all the woke issues their
number one issue climate change
um there or look and maybe New York
needs a new Hudson or a Lincoln Tunnel
or under the Hudson fine but no one in
the delegation comes and speaks with him
on crime they don't talk to about even
like bringing workers back into the city
they're they're nowhere and he's out
there fighting this by himself and I I
agree with the judge that you can
disagree with him on some things but you
have to admire him for he's he's trying
he's trying to be creative yeah and he
snuggles up in a sleeping bag and tries
to show all the illegals that it's not
that bad in Brooklyn and AOC hates the
man yeah so he must be good yeah exactly
what I'm saying exactly what's that line
an enemy of my friend is my enemy no
yeah my friend of me my friend and me
yeah my friends
go back to latinx I wanna Brian kill
Mead I want you to do me a favor I want
you to click to subscribe to the Fox
News YouTube page this is the only way
that I know for sure that you're not
going to miss any great commentary any
great news bites any great interviews
coming your way on Fox you can get it
all here on YouTube so subscribe right
now